sea gdx igual al coseno de x nos
preguntan bueno vamos a notar primero
esto en realidad tenemos que considerar
que las funciones coseno de x ahora cuál
es el valor de este límite el límite
cuando h tiende a 0 deje en ti más h -
gm sobre h entonces para eso primero
vamos a graficar la función muy bien ahí
ya lo hice por ustedes hace hace rato ok
para que sea más rápido y esta función
es digamos el coseno de x en el primer
periodo es decir entre 0 y 2 muy bien
esta es la forma tradicional del coseno
y vamos a ver qué es lo que nos están
pidiendo esencialmente primero nos piden
g de pi que nos fijemos en g de pi
aquí no nos paramos en pi y vemos que la
función justo se encuentra en su mínimo
verdad que es cuando vale menos 1
entonces este punto de aquí es el pi
coma
bien ahí tienen ustedes este punto y
ahora tenemos que fijarnos tenemos que
fijarnos en el punto g de pi más h
entonces si por ejemplo aquí anda más h
entonces nos fijamos en este punto de
aquí este de aquí tiene coordenadas y
más h coma que de pi más h
bien ahí estamos y ahora lo que nos
están pidiendo esencialmente es calcular
la pendiente que conecta desde la línea
que conecta estos dos puntos vamos a ver
porque tenemos que depp y más h en
realidad vamos a calcular esta pendiente
entonces tenemos que calcular el cambio
en la componente vertical es decir
tenemos que calcular que depp y más h
muy bien y restamos y restamos gd pi pi
y luego todo esto lo dividimos entre pi
más h
y más h menos que lo de abajo es el
cambio en x verdad entonces el primero
lo primero que tenemos es esta altura
verdad esta altura es gd pimas h - g de
pi y este cambio esta base digamos es
más h - pi verdad muy bien entonces si
nos damos cuenta bueno esto lo podemos
simplificar porque los pies se cancelan
y nos queda simplemente g
depp y más h - g de pi pi sobre sobre h
entonces si nos damos cuenta está
pendiente calcular la pendiente entre
estos dos puntos es justamente lo que
nos piden calcular sin aplicarle el
límite muy bien entonces ahora bueno
esencialmente si lo queremos ver aquí lo
que nos están pidiendo es la pendiente
de esta línea secante ahora nos piden
calcular el límite cuando h tiende a
cero es decir qué pasa si este numerito
de aquí lo vamos haciendo cada vez más
cercano a ti muy bien entonces
los puntos se van a ir acercando a este
mínimo verdad a este a este valle que
tenemos acá habrá si si fuera que nos
tomáramos la h negativa pues nos vamos
aproximando de esta de esta misma forma
ok entonces lo que nos piden aquí es
calcular la pendiente ya ya aplicando el
límite lo que tenemos que calcular es la
pendiente de la recta tangente pero en x
igual a pi entonces esto de aquí no es
otra cosa más que la pendiente
pendiente de la recta tangente de la
recta tangente
tangente y hay que decir en qué punto y
en este caso estamos pensando que es
este punto de aquí es decir en verdad
x igual a pi muy bien entonces si nos
fijamos en el vídeo por supuesto no
vamos perdón o en el vídeo el vídeo es
lo que estamos haciendo sino en la
imagen por supuesto hay formas de
calcular esto formalmente pero si nos
fijamos aquí tenemos un valle entonces
en este punto la recta tangente es
horizontal y sabemos que la pendiente de
las rectas horizontales es justamente
cero así que esto de aquí es cero
ok hay muchas formas de hacerlo hay
formas algebraicas de calcularlo no lo
haremos en este caso pero también lo que
podemos hacer es utilizar una
calculadora podemos usar una calculadora
para ir aproximando el valor del coseno
depp y más h y más h - el coseno de ti
entre h
/ h por ejemplo qué tal si calculamos
aquí ya había hecho unos ejercicios qué
tal si calculamos primero pimas h pi más
digamos 0.1
ya esto le calculamos el coseno muy bien
entonces esto es menos 0.99 5 quien sabe
que y le restamos el coseno de pi pero
el coche no de pi es menos 1 y si se le
restamos el sumarle uno
1 y ahora lo dividimos entre nuestra h
que fue 0.1 y vemos que esto es 0 puntos
0 49 digamos el 0.05 verdad entonces
esto es muy pequeño ahora para que se
vea más claro vamos a utilizar una h
mucho más pequeña digamos ahora vamos a
calcular pi más 0.0001 ok le calculamos
el cose no y ahora sumamos 1 que es
restar coseno de pi
1 y nos da 4.9 ok bueno pues por este
exponente por este por este exponente
digamos y hay que dividirlo ahora entre
h que nuestra h era 0.0001 muy bien y
eso nos da a 4.9 digamos esto es 5 por
10 a la menos 5 que esto se ve que ya es
muy pequeño entonces aquí vemos
claramente y con numeritos como este
valor se va aproximando cada vez más a 0